quello a tutti ragazzi e prevenute
questa novità sono frange oggi
finalmente possiamo fare un video su
fuga sono a pezzi hanno aggiunto vari
ostacoli in giro hanno risolto dei
problemi tecnici però delle mappe sono
un po cambiate ok vediamo cosa andiamo
avanti l'auto fuori
partiamo dal fatto che non so
effettivamente che cosa andranno ad
aggiungere o se questa sarà l'ultima
patch voluti a perché fanno prima che
finisca la season a prescindere da sta
roba ragazzi volevo dirvi una roba al
volo siccome ho registrato un paio di
video ancora della prima della patch nei
prossimi episodi poi guys capiterà che
ci sono ci sono delle partite che ho
registrato prima che oggi sta che sta
per quattro quindi non andava joystick
ma non vale ad amal dove andare ma che
c'è un joystick
la nuova beh cosa nome oddio sono volato
sono a posto a posto tutto ok ok ap
niente non mi andava al joystick non so
cosa sia successo
vi si vede che scarico con uno capito
comunque stavo dicendo usciranno dei
video ragazzi sul canale che ho
registrato prima che uscisse questa
patch quindi se non ci sono gli
aggiornamenti delle mappe e normale e
perché li avevo messi da parte sono
vittoria anche strafighe quindi le metto
però questo visto che la fece uscita
ieri volevo assolutamente varie vita
oggi con le nuove mappe vedere meno di
coda si tratta magari facciamo
capitolina lasciamo maledizione konami
sta cascando in faccia però solo terzo o
ragazzi
perché la gente mi deve toccare mettiti
la manina il culo di 100 ragazzi che
sono riuscito ad arrivare terzo sono
state non vi fosse partito il joystick
all'inizio c'è stata cosa avrà un senso
però vabbè però non ho visto niente di
nuovo rollout anche rollout mi sembrava
la prima quindi per adesso non ci sono
io allora parto vicino a mario ciao
mario
ok adesso è partito joystick meno male
no perché prima mi ha preso un ansia
arrivo le terribili ragazzi terribili
una bella partita roll out easy peasy
lemon squeezer quello si è suicidato
oddio quanta ansia di avere roll out
ogni volta mannaggia al vicolo è cascato
un tizio l'ho visto a posto non c'era
niente di nuovo rollout speriamo nella
prossima possa mangiare se 24 cacchio
allora 24 potrebbe uscire un unico i
giochi con le palle a non queste pensavo
l'altro questo sembra il gioco delle
palle raga io vedo tutto uguale non so
poi cosa hanno cambiato ok c'è roba
nuova li lancia roba nuova vedo ostacoli
rago che perfetto let's go forza gialli
ma vorrete spingete fattori the fate
cose va bene avere occhio che bruciano
quando tornando bene ragazzi continuate
a spingere bravi l'obiettivo ora che ve
lo dico sempre in questa il rock and
roll sempre arrivare primi e grazie un
cazzo pavia ve lo so però a volte si
buttano in avanti a prescindere perché
vogliono fermare gli altri è giusto ma
dipende dipende perché arrivare primi è
molto meglio sì ma adesso come facciamo
no vabbè maraga impossibile o no no no
no no no no no no no non è vero ma per
noi ragazzi non ci voglio credere
cosa c'è lui si può no non accadono
vabbè orribile stato ma cos'hanno fatto
da malaga
togliete qualche fate qualcosa addio lo
so di blu sono ok gustandola perfetto
allora non ce l'abbiamo fatta
teoricamente non spettacolare un
portiere ragazzi orribile terribile e
meglio di prima ma orribile per mac è
un'ansia meno male cosa un finiti male
noi
stavo dicendo quindi l'obiettivo
dovrebbe essere quello di questa fiction
speriamo che non abbiamo cambiato che
già era un casino prima
adesso sto pensare proprio a ragazzi qua
la tattica che utilizzo sempre molte
persone mela approvano bisogna
assolutamente aspettare che si butti la
gente primi furto io perché se vi
buttate tutti insieme a meno che non
parlate primi e se partite primi sono
svenuti tutti se partite primi buttatevi
no ma ragazzi ma arriva a duemila
all'ora l'affronta che è successo hanno
cambiato addio la velocità della frutta
ha cambiato ma è un presentimento mio
mio dio calmi taddeo e che a posto
dicevo se partite primi buttatevi se
invece partiti che aspettate che seduti
ma gli altri non buttate lì con loro
perché sennò fate voi di collisione
andate giunti guanti un catino fidatevi
non rimasti ragazzi e princiotto mi
sembrava uguali se non per il fatto che
secondo me non mentato con la velocità
della frutta madonna arrivando ai
cannoni e si opti 09 poi laura hexagon
perfetto ciò che hanno cambiato delle
robin fall montain quindi in hexagon non
lo so mi sembra uguale meno male perché
andavo benissimo ne dà quindi non
mancamento niente meno male che anche
adesso solo col monte che quella che
andava culo quindi se ne frega di extra
con l'impegno normale quindi devo fare
niente di strano effetto già già e la
partenza è orribile fatto le europee
orribili non importa per i figli adesso
non è vero raga la mia più brutta
partita di ex seconda quando ho memoria
praticamente perfetto e nonostante
questo sono tra quelli più alti tra loro
merito per niente allora continua stesso
percorso poi torni indietro così almeno
lì di una strada aspetta aspetta 32 ce
l'ho fatta avessero dato sia andato
apposta fasonisti perfetto va bene siamo
in due siamo in due sul giallo quindi
associato simile windows e giallo easy
peasy non è vero se mentre sul gioco
siamo in 4 sul giallo porco demonio
non so contare ti prego togliti danni a
piattaforma mannaggia a me ne sono
buttati via per forza
è per forza una gara che se non mi
faceva fuori tutte le blu
raga non c'è nessuno nella crew e cioè
dovrei avercela fatta
ma mancano due un nemico dov'è ecco a
posto sono un chilometro più in alto
teoricamente se me la gioco e quanto
vivi mori a donna che stava illimitato
sono troppo in alto si prolunghi solo
l'agonia
no ragazzi tra inciampando ciò io non ci
voglio che meno male provincia quando
giu mentre stava succedendo st vinciamo
meno male
va bene ma partiamo ho tagliato le prime
due perché tanto le prime due una volta
che abbiamo fatto se c'erano che se ci
fossero state novità la prima è se ma
erano due mappe normali wiring il quale
le porte quindi teoricamente qua per ora
non ci sono stati cambiamenti che ho
visto dei tag da sole hanno aggiunto
semplicemente degli ostacoli neal alcune
mappe però non so quali mi sa che sono
quelli di gruppo ragazzi comunque non
con le singole apple monte e ovviamente
l'obiettivo qua è sempre lo stesso raga
cercare di saltare da una piattaforma
all'altra a piattaforme nintendo questo
non tutti qua no maledizione akita
creato togliti è volato tizio madonna
che casino non ho via via via via via
via vinardi dei secondi prova strafare
un po raga perché vedo troppo casino
sulla piazza troppo bordello sulle
piattaforme ok tutto a posto dai va bene
non lo sa ben appurato se mi rubano la
coda da un chilometro sa non fai che
sanno fissato quella roba che ti rovina
la coda non km non ho visto and nextup
forma dei
dopo il gol tensione ma quando messo
delle robe o ragazzi hanno messo di
martelli che questa roba
fermi sono i martelli no ragazzi fermi
cos'è sta roba per i tutti
oddio nuova per un ora con dio una
spectre minati io sarò bene come faccio
maschi e vabbè ma non si possono anche
passare vicino
che parata ho fatto e vabbè è un
difensore incredibile rilancio sulla
destra raga sulla destra se temete la
palla sulla destra
mannaggia il vicolo c'è quella che la
butta dentro perché uno girare una in un
senso o in un altro gol abbiamo fatto
anzi due perfetto ok una banana c'è una
banana cosa hanno adesso le banane il
paul bowles è diventato poi il banana
veniamo valga più punti perché è una
donna sodio se la portiamo noi speriamo
regga più punti saputa allora no ecco no
vabbè ma ragazzi con martelli
impossibile però guarda guarda morath in
tv fanno non è male sta roba di martelli
difendere che quello di sinistra dipinge
fuori lanka colori destra sempre
mannaggia quindi a finalista perfetto
bravo favi il fariseo ti ha dato 191 e
una banana ma all'inizio arrivare almeno
tre punti ma porca vacca ho fatto
qualche una banale ragazzi sono un
fenomeno basta posto vinto l'altro
quando un ciò la sfida del del robot
gatto con la nuova perché ciò sul
computer ragazzi occhio occhio zio
madonna devo fare tutto io sta squadra
sempre difesa attacco guardalinee che
posso fare tutto io difesa attacco
centrocampo buttate la palla sempre
sembrate di destra perché quello che la
butta dentro
speriamo che con di nuovo dove volevo
vedere col monte maledizione però va
bene perché sono i nextone sono bravo
formont evase procuro quindi maledizione
va bene va venezia con chi se ne frega
col monte allora potrei provare a fare
la tattica quella che vedrete nel
prossimo video cioè quella di buttarsi
sull'ultima piattaforma e di togliere
l'ultima piattaforma
ho già fatto un video ragazzi come vi
dicevo l'ho già registrato in cui vinco
con quella tattica pazzesca uscirà tra
poco non tra gli ardori nuovo già che ho
fatto una vittoria ci riprovo ragazzi e
next con io vinco spesso sono tutti i
giochi sono tutti giù
devo solo tenere il tempo dicevo vinco
molto più spesso in in hexagon perché
c'è vinco quasi sempre meno ha detto che
lo dico probabilmente morirò dovrei
essere l'unico è non è vero forse no che
non lo so vorrei chi se ne frega ma
dovevano essere bellissimo fatto gli
stati pazzeschi ho avuto anche
abbastanza coraggio perché l'iran cadere
allenati o perfetto perfetto che dia un
senso per tenere con la gialla in
qualche modo se ne sto allungare fin
laggiù si non so se ci arrivo arrivo
mamma mia che giocatore ragazzi ok
ragazzi sono tutti io sono l'ultima
acqua teoricamente sì ma donna l'ho
fatto benissimo
ok proprio un po di strada o di hd
perfetto
un perfetto d'affetto perfetto perfetto
meno male che è caduto l'altro perché se
non cadeva l'altro forse avevo meno
strada io molto figo falbo il bellissimo
ho fatto anche qualcuna banana quindi
due vittorie una banana ma che volete di
più noi vi sia piaciuto ragazzi io
concludo che l'episodio il prossimo
uscirà questa settimana vi farò vedere
la vittoria che ho fatto flexa con
quella dove provi a togliere l'ultima
piattaforma già subito gli chiede del
calesse lanciare presidenti noi come
sempre ci vediamo l'anno prossimo vita
della ragazza
[Musica]